Well. Well, well go to your mom's house.
Christina.
Rolling into were bored.
They were aligned to where?
Before Ryan to where?
Board near Orlando.
Where you went to the airport?
Yeah.
This was the shit that
went through your pants.
This was the shit that went through
your pants. Yeah. Yeah. Listen,
the one where I had to leave my underwear
and I was in the brown spot in the crack
of a nostalgic moment.
You kicked out of me.
I'd be kicked out. I mean you're
rolling into where? Board?
Orlando airport in the
Orlando Airport near Orlando.
Double five classics
air coming out of both it
shit. Bedspread. I did
double five classics.
Yeah, there you go. Genes, double
pipe classics. Very rare event.
Rare event.
Oh,
Marianne
official.
I'm going to
Saint Louis
this week. Helium, one of the great clubs.
One of the really great bubs
helium experienced.
You've been helium
Saint Louis, Ted's. I'm going to be
going to helium September I believe. Oh,
and and Farland Hartland.
Yeah.
It's a really good chain of clubs.
Very happy to be going. So what
I hear, yeah, you can't go wrong.
It's the Orlando Airport of clubs.
That's a really good way of putting it.
Um,
so late
Saint Louis, Ted's, I um,
I'll be there this weekend.
Thursday, Friday and Saturday.
Please come see me then.
I have a week off genes. Can
you believe it? Oh my God.
Full week off. Um, and I go to Timonium,
which is just outside of balls and whores,
Maryland.
And I'm doing a megaphone IOM, is that
what it's called? Right? Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's not the joke word.
Timonium I've never heard of that place.
It's just outside of Baltimore.
I'll smell more balls. Smell more.
So much better now. Thank you all. Smell
more Maryland. I'm doing my boobies
comedy club August 4th,
fifth and six.
Please come out doing five shows and
the following weekend come on our bus,
Ohio at the funny bone there in Columbus.
So come see me if you're, if
you're around, I'll be there.
Very exciting.
The following week I'm doing my global
access global entry interview at lax.
That tickets to that one too. Yeah.
Hopefully people will come to me. Great.
Tsa loves that when you cause a scene
and joking and I had to move a couple of
dates.
I'm still not have not been given
permission yet to announce why.
Oh, so out on the horizon then. Yes,
but I can tell you that um,
New York's New York,
new Dork titties has been too door to
Jude or titties has been rescheduled.
It's only a the next month. So it wasn't
September. I had to move it to October.
It is now October 27,
28 and 29 and also another
ticket is now on sale.
And that is man Fran disco
or my favorite cities.
I'm doing cobb's October
20th through the 22nd.
All those tickets are at Thomson
[inaudible] dot com genes. What do you got
to do?
One nighters starting September 27th and
meet rattle Washington at the Tacoma on
your comedy club.
Uh,
September 27th and then
September 28th I'm in Shortland,
Oregon at helium comedy club.
That's what I'm doing here, ma'am.
October 4th I'm in Fallis,
Texas and hyenas. Comedy
Club. October 5th posting.
That's good. Okay. How said the secret
group? That's good. And then October 23rd,
that's Indianapolis. Dino, anyone?
Indian crapless, Andy
crapless, Indian crap Willis.
That's very racially insensitive.
Tom,
there's something somebody sent in
a wild Yak crabs. Really good sweat,
but I don't remember what it was.
Anyways,
that's what we're doing.
Mortise comedy club. October 24th, uh,
Cincinnati Fist and Daddy Ohio's.
And then if by Jeff
thank,
it's crazy in here.
There's so many jokes that La la La la.
Yeah. And Oh and I added a local date.
I am headlining the Ice House. Uh,
July 23rd eight o'clock show.
Get your tickets.
All these tickets blinks are on
thousand branch.com on my tour page.
Excellent.
Links to your tickets.
Did you say [inaudible]
dot com and that's it.
That's it on my end guys. Oh, July
29th. Can we take a joke is coming out,
a limited release in theaters and then
August 1st available for download on
iTunes.
Such excellent.
Um,
check it out guys.
This episode of Your Mom's house is
brought to you by the Burbank comedy
festival and luckily for you and for us,
we are going to be there as well.
The Burbank Comedy Festival Takes Place
August 14th through 20th at flappers
Comedy Club in restaurant.
Join us and Christopher Titus.
Kate Flannery drew lynch and about 250
new and emerging comedians from all over
the world.
After a full day of laughs,
relax at one of 18
fantastic Burbank hotels.
Conveniently located just around the
corner from flappers for best hotel rates
and a special VIP festival pass.
Go to Burbank comedy festival.com
is sponsored by the downtown Burbank
Partnership Visit Burbank.
We're super excited to be
doing this. Uh, we've always,
as you guys know,
gone to flappers and this is a good
chance to come and see a bunch of cool
comedy taking place in that area.
Um, it's a, it's a week long,
August 14 through August 20th,
50 special events,
underground showcases industry
panels, after parties, live podcasts,
obviously because Christina and I will
be doing your mom's house podcast live
Monday, August 15th. So
please come and see us.
Uh,
we'll get the link up and uh,
it should be a packed house and a
lot of fun and uh, we're excited.
We're excited to be part of this.
What a
great idea to have like podcasts and
stand up and everything in one area in one
week. Yeah. It's pretty cool. Flavors is
a great place. If you haven't been there,
you got to check it out. I love
their chicken wings. It's awesome.
I have the best comedy club food in the
business. It's really good. Besides sides,
Schomburg, Improv, they have one good
dish, the chicken and I like, yeah,
there's a couple clubs. I really good
food. Yeah, it's rare. It is rare.
Like a double pipe classic.
Very rare.
Good food at a comedy club is the
double pipe classic of having food.
That's good. It really is. It's
very hard to do. They don't go well.
Uh, I'm excited to be a part of it.
I love flapper. So yeah, it's um,
it's cool that a club is
even lasted that long.
It's so hard to make a comedy club out
of nowhere. Success out of nothing.
And can I tell you, I, you and
I are friends with the owners.
We've known them for years and they were
comedians and there are two comics who
decided to do their own club and they
work their balls and tits off. Yeah.
And a lot of people doing that but never
do it and they worked so hard and it's
such a great place. So go support
flappers it's a mom and pop shop.
Uh, they're very cool people. Yeah,
it's pretty great guys. Also, please,
if you're shopping on Amazon,
I hope you are.
Please use our banner on your mom's house,
podcast.com.
Just click on the banner at
the bottom of the homepage.
Do Your shopping as you normally would.
Um,
and did you celebrate Amazon Prime
Day, Tom? I did not sound right. I did.
It was July 12th and I even got even
greater discounts on my Amazon purchases.
How did you do that?
You just shop as you normally would.
They just have like markdowns on stuff.
Really. It was really cool. So yeah,
use our banner please. So you just, can
you explain to me a little more? No,
it's just a day that they say like mark
down stuff for Amazon prime members and
then you just shop. We buy more
stuff that you need. You know,
like I got little jeans,
some swim diapers.
So when we take him swimming
in the pool and he shits it,
they don't have to drain the
pool. Right. Cause I, you know,
baby shaky Tammany and stuff.
All right. You ready to do
this? Yeah, of course. Yeah.
Born born right.
Here we go.
One of FARC, FARC. And
you really fired, fired,
fired, fired, fired. Sorry. Have we
sang that song on the show yet? Um,
no, not a wine. That's just, uh, that's
personal song. Yeah. We haven't
shared that with the world.
Let's go.
Do you feel like you eat?
Thanks a lot, Rachel. Oh, loved
Frank's to you, Matt charging.
Not charging on my iPad because it's
got youth to your iPad instead of mine.
It's not charging my pad and it's all job.
Oh,
I hope y'all happy because I've told mom
no,
bring it
to your mom's house,
Christina.
Okay.
This is my second of the day. Actually.
I know you just interviewed your parents.
Yes. Big News. Topdog
and Charo right in here.
We did an hour. Where did she sit here?
No, she sat there. Td got this one.
Oh boy.
There was some ridiculous stuff.
So what are we going to
get to hear that one?
Um, I dunno cause everything
right now, the yard, you know.
Right. And I had Maria in here. Yeah.
So I got, I got a bunch of stuff.
We have Maria at the house,
I should say.
I got some quality time with my sister in
law. And while you were gone, oh my God,
seriously. It was Omg, Maria,
her baby and me and our baby.
And it was a whirling dervish.
Seriously. Seriously. Seriously.
Seriously. Seriously, seriously.
I mean your sister was
up at 5:00 AM with a kid
first day. So people know, you know,
Los Angeles does have a lot of hills. You
know, there's like there's hills. Yeah.
In different regions of the city.
We live in a neighborhood that built on
a hillside and it is almost entirely at
an incline, like you pull in the
neighborhood and you know, it's just,
it's all uphill. Yeah. Day One. She,
I get up and she's been up there.
She's like, hi. Yeah. Hi. Yeah.
Actually I can tell she's been outside.
You know, she's wearing it. Yeah.
And then she's like, like, she's got sun
and she's sweating. I go, what'd you do?
I was going, I went on the
run. I go, where'd you run?
Just through the neighborhood. And I
go, how far do you run? And she goes,
five miles, five miles.
How did you know? She goes,
I download an APP and it tells
you where to go. And I go,
this neighborhood's like all uphill.
And she goes, yeah, me and my daughter,
she did a stroller run
up hill for five miles.
No, I know. And then she's ready for the
day. And then that's when they start.
Now she's like, I'm ready. I'm
ready for the day. She jacked.
So at one point I'll just tell you this,
I don't know even know if I told
you the whole story. I won't.
What I want it to hang some
lights in the backyard.
I bought some wides on Amazon, I wanted
a bed, we had big plans for these lights.
You and I went to the hardware store,
we bought like bamboo rods
and try to hang, you know,
like those years in restaurant lines.
So I figured to keep your sister occupied
because I don't like doing stuff.
Right. Okay. And I can say I s I
knew it already when we were a low,
what are we gonna do today? Know it was
kind of wondering, we're not happen.
So I think I figure I'm going to keep
Maria occupied and I'm going to make it
her project to hang up the lights.
Yeah.
And I'll just kind of chill out with Ellis
and you know, watch the chaos unfold.
Well the chaos and folded your sister is
like, okay, where can we plug these in?
And then she found one outlet and
then, you know, outcomes, the wiring.
And then I go, I listen, we,
we need to dig holes to put
the bamboo in the grass.
I go, we don't want, we don't
have a shovel. I don't know
how we're gonna do this.
That's okay. I'll just, I'll go get
a spoon. She goes into our kitchen,
she's the one that thought of that.
She thought of that of course,
got a spoon and then one of
our knives cooking knives,
she pulls it out of the thing and I,
before I know it,
she's already digging with a nice kitchen
knife and a spoon. And I go, Maria,
I think we got to abort this mission.
I have something tells me this is
not the right way to do lists. I go,
let's just a board, are you sure?
Cause I think I can figure this out.
We're going to do this. I'm like,
no, you can't do that. Then she goes,
why don't I just climb up these trees
and climb the trees and I'll put them in
the trees. I'll just climb up the
trees and I go, what? And she goes,
I climb trees every day. It's fine.
It's fine. I was like, I don't think so.
Maybe not this time. Do you have
a ladder? I go, forget it. No,
it's crazy.
Your sister wanted to dig holes with
spoons and knives and then climb arteries.
She's crazy. Total crazy. That's her.
That's been her since we were kids. Yeah,
quite an imagination and always going.
Never stops. Never stops.
It's never seen her retired.
Just goes so much.
A couple of things. First of all, how
adorable is this, Bro? I'm telling mom.
It's also interesting that she told this.
I presume this is her sister,
but she told her via video message.
That's maybe just what kids do now.
Right? We don't leave notes now.
This is the no opposed to note a
video note. I hope. God, thanks a lot.
Thanks it auction Ethiopia. Thanks
a lot Mitchell. Thanks a lot.
Thanks to you. Matt is not
charging on my iPod because he's
not trying to.
It's all on them because
I've told mom happy.
I hope y'all happy.
I've told mom
is great. She so mad yet. Yeah, look at
that. That's such a stern talking to you.
I hope y'all had backs. So cute. Oh Mom,
what did she mean?
The iPad gets used to someone's charged.
There is a weird thing with chargers
sometimes when you plugged them into
certain devices like the same,
I don't know that it's a thing,
you know that's been proven, but you
put it in yours, you're like, oh,
it doesn't work. Somebody else puts
it in there as, and it charges.
Is that true to ban? Yeah. Oh,
that's a new one. Thank you.
I got that from the
Internet. Oh really? Yeah.
I was going to tell you someone called
Dj man. Make that up. That's fine.
I'll take it.
Excellent.
Is that true? I have seen it
happen before. I'll be like, oh,
this device doesn't recognize this wire.
I've seen weird stuff. Oh yeah, yeah,
I've seen that.
Legit.
She's fired up,
man.
I did one of those things.
You remember how forever we didn't realize
we could just put an extension cord
so you can plug things on your
side of the bed. So dumb. Yeah,
and I was so many things for
so long. I know. I'm like,
we can just plug it in and an extension
cord and you're like, oh my God.
And then the other one
was we just had one,
a charger for our devices,
like for r three two iPads.
Two iPhones.
Yeah. And then I was at a mall
like a month ago and I go,
I'm going to buy more chargers so that
now we could charge more stuff at once.
It was like a breakthrough thought for me.
What's wrong with us?
I think you and I are like Frat boys.
Like whatever's happening is fine.
We'll just make,
just make it do we just get used to
this because we were broke for so long.
That's why I don't think we
realized we can spend $12 now on it.
She actually, and they
fucking rob you. Seriously.
How much is first of all,
they conveniently, they go,
we were selling just the chart.
Like the plug in the charger has one
now they sell the part that goes in the
wall. No. Or that goes on
your device separately. Both.
And I think one's 29
and one's mother fucker.
You buy like a $50 no. Yeah.
Yeah. It's expensive. Very
get your entire life. Yeah.
It's expensive. What about that one
we have downstairs and the kitchen.
That's just a one piece.
It looks kind of old school.
[inaudible] that one's a
gray charger by yeah. Yeah.
That one is made by an
outside. That's good. Yeah.
We got to get more of that for cheaper.
I mean they all those people,
those was the way to go. There's that
much cheaper, such scumbags. Crazy.
But they make such good shape. By the way,
do you want to hear somebody made a, um,
a version of your mom's house?
Yeah.
This is Dj wet nut sack.
Okay.
It's his version of the associates.
The as big Tam who is Randy,
don't bring anyone loving to this.
Your Mama and the funk is style.
Well, the hair, your mom's house
said
your mom's house
sounds like the uh,
the South Park.
A teacher. You what I'm talking
about? Yeah. Mister Mister.
Hey Mr. Garrison. Yeah. It's
like Mr. Garrison has doing this.
You know this guy?
No.
But he did submit something like a week
or two ago and he was so stoked to your
stuff that you submitted us like a whole
book. Oh, okay. Okay. All right. Well I,
this is very interesting.
You got that part right
there.
Purposely said those things.
Oh,
okay.
Good job. Good job, Dj wet notes at
your mom was in the fucking stage.
There's a cutting that and stains and
he'll tell you how this is supposed to go.
Okay.
This shit is big time.
Come on now. Who is Randy?
That's good job. Oh,
bring anyone loving there.
Don't bring any was mother into this.
Your Mama and the funk is stay or what?
Your mom and the fucking
stands, man. Come on.
You got to listen to at Patrion
episode where we break down this intro.
We just spent like 30 minutes covering
this. Which episode is that? Blue Bat? Uh,
I think that might be episode three on
patriotic [inaudible] dot com slash mom.
There you go. Uh, yeah, we go into detail.
Do you want to hear the every of
how the intro was made? Um, yeah.
Patrion on.com/. Dot. Um,
put that shit down. So then you had,
you had Mario with you for a few days.
I'm exhausted. So your sister
left and I, I felt so tired.
Like I think that's what, why I'm still
so exhausted is just having any guests.
Yeah. And then having your sister
who's just having two babies, her baby,
our baby,
we had nonstop tears.
So many cries and then family was here
yesterday and that was exhausting and
really get together yesterday.
We dead. Yeah, we sure. Did
she talk about who wasn't
at the gathering? No.
Who? Oh yeah, go ahead. Can I
tell them what we did yesterday?
Are you okay with that? Sure, of
course. He baptized our son Ellis,
so now he's going to go to
heaven. Um, and uh, so I,
we invited the whole,
the clan,
the there was already was baptized
cause every time we see this blue band,
he cries on the right path.
That's good.
He knows he's not Christian.
Right. So we extended the invitation to
everybody and their families and my dad,
I told him like months ago,
this is happening. It's like,
oh, I can't go. I'm like,
why? Why? It's you're, you're
only grandsons baptism.
What can be more important
than, Oh, I'll go into Vietnam.
So my dad left on like Thursday.
The baptism was on Sunday.
Like you couldn't move that
ticket, Bro. A couple of days.
It's so crazy. Right. Could've
could've left today. I love now.
Still still be there in time for all the
art he's looking at and it doesn't have
work. All the art he's looking at it
probably it's a probably a cultural trait,
I'm guessing why it's so important
for him to be there. Well,
for you to say something
like that, I mean, maybe go
over where his last few trips
while he goes to other countries
like the Philippines or Thailand,
Brazil,
places known for their
culture and their art work.
Yeah.
I'm not sure that tied
in. I bought it. Did
you watch toes? I don't know
how you think. I don't know.
And I know what the common denominator is
with all these countries. Yeah, I dunno.
He got a stiff
and going after her better. I
don't know. So we'll, you know,
we'll see how that shakes down when
Ellis is old enough to ask why is it
grandfather in any way,
these photos.
Yeah.
So he couldn't make it
how that'd people made it.
People made it just fine,
but other people didn't
have trips planned.
Horrible. Oh my gosh. I got, I talk
to my shrink tomorrow for sure.
It's normal for him though. It start off.
Yeah, of course. For him. Yeah. Yeah.
What do you think the logic
w w what was happening? Um,
I just think that like in his case,
he doesn't,
he doesn't think like the
way that others at all. Oh,
sorry. It's just, it's so
outside of his mindset.
Yeah. To go like, just to think like
that. To think like a human, oh no,
not like a human, like a person with
feelings. Oh, your dad's got it.
Kind of a one track kind of
focus on him, I think. You know.
Uh, yeah. I think, I think
it doesn't occur to him.
And even if you were to tell him, you
know, all the reasons like, hey, you know,
you should be here for this. And
yeah, I wasn't going to do that. Yeah,
I totally get that. But I
think he would go like, okay,
like I'll do that that cause
you asked me to do that. Yeah.
He doesn't think like I should do that.
No, there's no, there's no should.
I think that's the whole thing
with him is that there was never,
I ought to do x instead of y or Z.
Yeah.
He just does what he wants. You
know? There's no, there's no art.
There's no control. It's just
I what I want. All right.
Yeah.
That's a really heavy stuff sometimes.
Mm.
Yeah, and we'll scale it was this place.
It's interesting. That was crazy. Wait,
what? Now let's, okay, what's
his house didn't give it almost,
well that was going to
be a whole ordeal though.
We had to find a place for him and all
that stuff. I know it didn't work out. No,
it didn't work out. It's just so
it's, but it's interesting because,
but now that I think about it, I'm
not even sure, you know what I mean?
Like when you have a parent that's
a little kooky shoes, do even,
is it that parent that you want at these
events or is it the idealized version?
It's a good point, right?
Like I'm not even sure
for a long, long, long time.
You keep requesting the thing you want
right from the, from said person. Right,
right. It doesn't have to be
parents. It can be a friend.
It can be a sibling spouse,
right. Yeah. In, in different, uh,
scenarios like this. Yeah. And then you
get to the point where you're like, oh,
it's okay that said person,
right. Is Not at anything.
Or I just have to change my
expectation of set of person.
Yeah. Cause then that part isn't, you're
not going to get what you want. Yeah.
Maturity, man. Yeah. That's the part,
that's the thing that takes a long time.
40 years. I'm with you. I'm
seeing a shrink at the same,
same, same thing too, is like,
it's always about your expectation.
You're right with your
social, your parents switching
when you become a parent.
Yeah.
No. Wow. Was that synergy
[inaudible] synergy. Yeah.
Yeah, yeah. Yeah.
So anyway, that was our
weekend. The family came. It
was a great time yesterday.
Top Dog and Charo Maria and
her husband that Bri, Bri,
my, my cousins came from
Riverside. My aunt. It was great.
She's hilarious. She's so, she's
the most normal besides my cousins,
the most normal person who squeezed into
my family. She's a social worker. Yeah.
Sweet Lady. She's retired now, but
like the sweetest person. So you know,
we had, we had a great time. Yeah,
it was great. It was going to,
her son's going to heaven
and hopefully we'll have a
cool pictures from Vietnam too.
Maybe I'll have a new mom. I
don't know. And I got to check.
This is cause this is Shara or maybe
you'll have a new brother or sister,
half Vietnamese.
Who knows? What does she say? She asking
about dinner? This is what she said.
Holy Shit.
You want to press pause and read that and
know it's going to take everything. Um,
it's an awfully long tech so you sure
you don't want to pause and read that.
Is it okay?
Yeah, yeah. I kind of skimmed
it. It's fine. It's fine.
It's my mom basically saying,
sweet plus.
I want to be nice to have course.
Oh sorry. That was the
wrong button. No, so gross.
You better get your life.
Anyway.
I'm excited that we're back
together again and the mommy dome.
Me Too. I love doing the show. People
ask me all the time on the road,
you know about how much pussy you get.
Well like I'll fuck a girl, right?
Like in the green room. And then she'll
be like, I love this. I love your
thanks. Then she's like, uh, like do you
like doing stand up or the podcast more?
I love doing standup. I don't think I'll
ever stop loving stand up. It's like my,
my love.
Uh,
but there's nothing is fun as
coming back and doing this podcast.
I really enjoyed this isn't it?
Yes. Our home. We got our world.
This is our silly little worlds.
It's very fun. It was neat.
I asked you to put my phone on the
charger last night cause I was asleep and
then he didn't do it right and I got
mad at you and when I walked over and it
was like God punish me because you farted
and it was like a hot garbage fart.
It was hot trash.
It was really disgusting.
The made me so happy.
It made me so happy.
What did you,
now that wasn't just dinner because
my farts didn't smell like that.
What did you eat on the road prior?
Actually it was a pretty health healthy
road weekend. Yeah. San Diego, California.
You can find like vegetables
and shit. Now. How's your
IBS update? Do we have one?
There's not really much of one. Well there
is an update. Um, I did always, you know,
you don't want to have the doubts.
So I went and I cleared the whole
food allergy thing off the table.
Okay. I got tested across the board and
there's nothing, no food allergies. Great.
Yeah. So that's, that's a relief.
And then when are we going
to be home for a few weeks
and then lagging me a drink?
I have to clear my whole system out.
You mean you have to shit a lot? Yeah.
Yeah, I've heard that is intense.
Like I heard that you shit a lot.
Like he ever drink that dieters t that
Asian dieters who by accident I one time
in college I did so like slimming tea.
You just Shit Shit Shit.
I think it's like a,
it's pretty intense and I think it
actually is over a day of doing that.
Just shedding. I think maybe
I'll weigh in against burden,
but when I do that you got
to clear your calendar.
You're gonna lose like 10 pounds.
You wanted me to everybody.
I'm so this is,
this is the original original.
This guy's back, but let's, let's,
which bathroom is use? My God,
I talked at length about
that topic with my parents.
I got really serious
trying to have fun with gender
pronouns and then I definitely about,
I'm saying there's a transgender and he's
in the women's room when he's there to
rape.
I don't think that happens.
Okay.
He said they're there to rape.
Oh No.
All right. All right. Did you
ask your dad what is Pronoun?
I played in the clips of the pronouns
guy explaining stuff and they were just
like,
okay
my mom just like so are you
eat a day or them there?
My Dad actually made a good
point. He goes, well what happens?
I'm like you guys speak Spanish and
that's a masculine feminine language. Yes.
And I was like that's a
good question. Yes. Um,
but then we kind of figured out that
you could like instead of saying like a
Giddy,
you could say like [inaudible]
which is a disaster.
Yeah.
Cause in German there's within the words
still not just the word right before it,
the words end up being, you have to
match it to the feminine and masculine.
That's very German. You have deed dare
or dos, masculine, feminine and Neuter.
So they accommodated as well.
Maybe the neutral force both get ace.
Oh God.
It managed anyways. He got
just manage all scared. Ace.
I love this guy.
So
hello guys. I know, I know.
I am still seeing go.
I am seeing go and I am
looking for a girlfriend.
Yes, I am looking for a girlfriend.
If you know a girl who is single,
please tag her right now because I want
to go in the relationship with that
guilt. All right. I want to go in
the relationship with that guilt.
If you know a girl who was single,
tag her right now because
I am looking for guilty.
Go in the relationship. I want to go.
You can't go to the movies with me.
Hold hands with me,
have sex with me.
I am looking for low guilt.
You can go in the relationship with me.
So if you know a girl who's single plays,
tag her right.
There's so much wrong because I
am single and I want to date her.
We know number one, maybe not
film in front of the toilet. Yeah,
I mean pick any other spot
on campus. Yeah, it's not,
it's not ideal right now. One, it's too
desperate. Women don't want that. No,
that's too much, but he's back. I
can't wait. I think he learned. Okay.
Let's see.
Let me just definitely more serious.
That was kind of silly kind of goofy.
Fuck. Look at, look at that face now.
Oh, he's grown up. Oh he looks
like he's raped. If you girl,
oh my God, what am I? God I look,
I'm not saying he did.
I'm just saying that's an intense no,
he just knows what it is to get a nut now.
Like he knew he got his nut.
I think he's actually been in there a
few times, so now it's more serious.
You know he was going for, what
happens is when you're a young,
young man, you're like Hee Hee Hee. Right.
And you think that can get
girls, it doesn't get girls. No,
it doesn't go good girls that want, when
you want to close the deal. What's a,
what do you mean you gotta be like a jerk,
not a jerk. I think. I think that like,
that silliness is not
how you get when you're,
especially when you're young, you know,
cause it's not label energy. Right.
It's goofy energy and girls, I want to leg
cause we energy lets you, the thing is,
unless you hang out with girls. Yeah,
but it's a nonthreatening type of thing.
It's a buddy buddy. At our g and right
here he learned. He learned that,
that's friend energy. This
is Dick Energy, right? Yeah.
I going to have this calm
energy. Yeah. Yeah. Look at that.
Do you tell right away he's all about
business. He's like, I've found a girl.
The other one is seeing
his face like ah yeah,
I've had sex with goals. He knows
now emails. Let's see if he knows.
I think he knows now.
Okay.
Hey guys. Okay. Better. Once again,
I am looking for girlfriends
the now I've got a chest. Yes,
I got a six pack and I went
back to tell you that no chest,
no sex. So I am back and I'm
looking for your friend. All right.
I am looking for girlfriend.
So if you know kill who is single tag are
right now because I am looking for Gil
to sleep on my body to touch my six pack.
Yes.
And I want to kill you.
Go to the movies of me holding
hands with me and has sex with me.
So if you know Gil,
who can resist and not resist my sixth
body tag and right now because I got a
chest and a six pack and
I am looking for guilty
know, oh my God, I think maybe
he didn't fully learn the lesson,
the correct. It sounds like a, a gay disco
in the background. Yep. And number two,
this only works this approach on other
data. You've said this before. Yeah.
This is, this is actually a great lesson.
Gee, this is not for women. He Won.
This is masculine towards men.
Guys that don't know that.
Yeah. It's usually younger.
Like he's a young guy.
He doesn't know they go because they're
so overwhelmed with their sexual
desires. Know how to get it. He doesn't
know what to do. Frustrated. Yeah. Yeah.
This isn't, he's, he's on the right path.
Booboo. You're almost there. Yeah. If,
if I were, I mean, good advice
would be what? Throw on a shirt. Um,
maybe talk,
there's gotta be some interest in no,
I think because the kind of girl he needs.
Yeah.
I don't think he's busted
that first night. Really.
He needs a girl who he needs a
gal who can, who's into the body,
the mind. Some girl who's
a real pig, who's his age,
who is like, I don't get it.
I'm a fan of that. About him.
That's the sky off. Like,
like your slut girl voices.
Yeah.
So he needs it to keep the shirt
off but not say what he wants.
He should talk about something else. Yeah.
And then girls will be all, oh my God,
we got a Hottie as like,
you know, Justin Bieber.
He used to do it where he'd
just be like, hey, you know,
and then you just don't talk
about wanting to fuck somebody.
I gotta look at that stare.
Oh my God, he's so into it.
He's got so much calm inside this raging
through his veins right now. Yeah.
You can smell it. It's too
much. Yeah. Poor guy. Yeah.
Can somebody please lay this guy?
Are you in New Zealand listening?
Can you find the guy that needs a
girlfriend if too much? What is his name?
At least say your fucking name.
And the video just says Chinese guy.
I know you might not even be
Chinese isn't racist Internet thing.
That's fucking Chinese guy.
I'm looking for a Gal. Um, I'm
looking for, he's really sweet.
Oh yeah. Well I dunno. I think
you've maybe got a little less sweet.
Yeah, he got, he got, he's just
angry. He's got testosterone nuts.
It was nuts. Need to get trained.
Somebody during that guy's nuts, please
guys. Let's do a Kickstarter
to drain this dude's a fly.
Someone there to drain his
nuts. That'd be great. Yeah. Um,
so many, so many fun things to talk
about. Oh, speaking of racist, um,
this lady, I as a white woman
and she has her own bed company.
Is that what it is?
She has a bed company.
I think that's just like her gimmick
or something. Right. And she is that,
it looks like, um, almost
like a company party of some
kind. Right. It's like, it's,
it seems like it's a
business related party.
Definitely a crowd full of her friends.
Yeah. And she sings a song yeah.
At this party.
Yeah.
About being a Ninja and goes
into a full Asian mockery of it.
And there's an Asian woman right next
to her who's face changes throughout the
performance. She's like,
oh, and then she's like,
you're being so racist right
now. Yeah. Oh, let's see.
Okay. Let's see. It's um,
it's pretty incredible.
Why is this not working?
Do a command.
Thank you.
[inaudible]
right boy. And this lady is
Jennifer Murphy beds. Um,
so here she is.
Okay.
[inaudible] yeah,
I shut my Murphy.
That's down to scratch my head.
What could this day brings right now?
Get the phone call.
I gotta go.
Go with there. But today,
tell him that scandal.
And at this point you're like,
all right,
she's singing the song and she's singing
it kind of in her what her voice would
be. Yeah. Then she
definitely shifts gears now.
And then curious lady,
it gets a little more curious.
Take me long to find the ticking bomb.
Chow is such a,
Craig,
I got to take downtown one day.
Not me.
Maybe.
Maybe I put could be Ninja.
I want to challenge,
I love it so much and I love it.
What is this song?
Is this a real song? Something
else? Do you know this song? No.
I don't know exactly how I'm mortified
this woman. Right? Yeah, I know.
Please keep playing.
Oh,
it's so embarrassing.
They started framing
thank God could go far.
I am a natural smile
with grantees,
cars,
even wealthy being done.
I used to all my knee just,
yeah. Soda. Yeah.
Solid rock.
I can't listen to it. It's hard. It's
so bad. It's like, oh my God. It's um,
it's embarrassing. Great. Yeah. And she
really offended that lady for sure. Yup.
Yeah. Good job. Yeah. So
that was really horrible.
No, yeah, it's really
bad. You reminds me of,
for some reason that summertime is great
people. Oh yeah. It's made shitty music.
Like it's almost a,
yeah.
This is almost too stupid to really
be offensive because you're like, oh,
she's just a dang dog.
It doesn't know what she's doing.
I would say that for sure. But, um,
word summertime, people should be fucking,
um, yeah. The worst. That was the worst.
There was the absolute worst.
Yeah. Um, you made a good song.
I just remember seeing that a second ago.
Yeah.
Wait a minute.
I think we should have a little contest.
This just reminded me.
Yeah. You know Nick Hog,
I think we've determined that his
worst song is breaking a sweat.
Did, did we read what he wrote or the
the, the email we got? Yeah, we did. Yeah,
yeah,
yeah. You read it on the
show? Yes. Yes. Okay.
Now I'm saying apropos of this,
I nominate because I know how hard it is
to make music and I don't like to just
shit on people arbitrarily.
I'm going to put my song animal song up
against Nick Hawks breaking a sweat and
you tell me who song is better.
Christina put jetskis animal song
or nick hawks breaking a sweat.
I just to show that like I don't just
shit on people without putting my own hat
in the ring.
This is the first song I wrote.
I have a feeling breaking a
sweat as his first song and
this is garbage garbage
ring such correct. It's
embarrassing. Got a lot
so fucking bad. That's the fucking
worst song I've ever heard. God,
you give it 18 seconds.
You just trashed it because I'm just
saying I don't think animal song is worse
than that. I've written one song in my
life. It is animal song. Okay, here it is.
Maybe two songs.
My life.
Here's my animal song and you guys
tell me who makes a worst song.
Me Or Nick Hawk.
Right. It's pretty good. I
still like it more for sure.
It's better than me.
It
was so hard to get these
seagulls to sing at the same time
or difficult.
Yeah.
Take off like a jet.
You watching TV,
you don't know who can bet on them again?
This dog shit. Yeah.
So we got a dog. Shit.
We have an email come in about,
you know, God, that's my angers me.
I'll fucking give me the
car. Tried to get us,
get that taken down for it because
we talked about them in an episode.
Um, but we just played a moment of it,
you know, just to talk about it. Yeah.
He has some comments on his
video. Uh, it says, hey mommy,
just checking in high and tight.
There
a one said low and Louis no common.
These balls. I think we might.
We may finally, no, I
Burke Chrysler. So fad.
It looks like he hasn't found the com
you should stick to fucking old white
women. Your music career was over before
it started. Nick Hock is a calm dog.
Question Mark. Um, so we
heard his song. Your Song.
How about my song? Yeah. What's yours?
This is the reason it
sounds way better than all
this looks good plot holes.
Pot Holes.
Why did my ice cubes
smell like a butthole?
The smell. The smell. The smell.
Pretty good.
Yeah. It was like still better
than break is really powerful.
Waiver the break.
But hold my first song I ever made
by the time it's something that I actually
kept in the freezer. It's gone bad
but holds kids the original holes,
black holes,
but we don't eat anything
that smells like buttholes.
That's my favorite part. Dad did it.
Yeah. See, between the three of us,
that was your original song. Uh,
animal song was my original song.
I made it with nothing but my
pewter. Same with you. Still better
than what Nick hawked it in a studio.
It is. What he did was really bad.
What did he, it was really bad.
And he should I shoot her an apology song.
You should make an album of songs
that apologize for this whole album.
It's a good idea. Yeah. I'm
apologizing. Apologizing on the booth.
Apologize around for breaking a sweat.
Oh my God. Yeah. That whole
album is really terrible.
Yeah. Let me get the memories.
You got the country song too. Oh
boy. That was the only good ones.
These have no views. I mean like
the view counts on them are so,
so weird. Tiny. It's really weird. Yeah.
Like a dude farting has more accounts
in these. He has a video here.
It's been up for eight months. It's
one of his songs, has 42 views.
How does it,
the house, it's almost impossible to
have that little views and eat anything.
Oh, he did make the, remember
he was, we watched as official
music video. Yeah, yeah,
yeah. That does have some views on it, so.
Okay. Well these people are checking in,
seeing what the Hawk is up to. Um, yeah.
It was really bad, man. You're really bad.
At that, but you're not bad
at Hoe and I've seen you Ho
guy works out.
He weren't, he lays. Yeah. You know,
you just a better Ho then
you are working on my raps.
Jesus.
You know what made me laugh?
Just sitting in my car today was just a
linkedin is helpful then as helpful as I
in my head I hear and a giggle and then
I hear Joey Diaz going Lincoln then,
well no vulgar language or loses a link.
And then
he got so upset about that.
I don't fuck with Lincoln,
Lincoln and Lincoln. Then do I have, um,
what's his name stuff here. I used
to have his stuff. Mark in a sweat.
Breaking a sweat linked linkedin
is helpful.
It's not a joke.
I don't give a shit.
Don't say a fucking thing
to get it, asshole. He used to get so mad.
I know. That was the best part. I
know. I think guys such a crazy person.
God don't bring up your mom's house
so crazy.
Um, okay, so this, by the way,
um,
it's something we always,
we always want to pay credit
to the best of the best.
Uh, the people that really
do it right. And, um,
there's not, you know,
there's always an argument for
who is the champion,
who's the,
who's the best. Here we
go. No, we've got a 2001.
Yes, yes. Allen's great.
That's, that's so great.
Classic. There's so many
great ones. I'm saying
why K W I s
and this is, this is
right. This is it there.
The Diego Sanchez. Yeah.
Yeah, it's pretty good.
And the majority of this sport is,
is really just all about the
mental aspect of it, you know? Um,
I believe it eats first and foremost.
It's the training that you put in,
in the gym and you know,
that's what's going to give you that base,
a mental strength because you can,
you know,
you're going to believe in
yourself because of the hard
work that you put in the
gym and you know, as far as it
goes for me, you know what I mean?
At once you stepped in that cage. Of
course, you know, it's, it's all mental,
you know what I mean? You have
to, you have to have 100%.
We have to be 100% at the time when
it's time, you know what I mean?
Not 100%. You know,
right before the fight.
It's 100% when it counts,
when it's all on the line.
Well mean. Interesting. First of all, I
think he has a lot of good things to say.
Yeah. Yeah. I liked it. He varies
between your nose and he says,
you know what I means? What
kind of, he really articulates
it. Yeah. Sometimes it's,
you know what I mean? You know what I
mean? But he goes, you know what I mean?
Right.
It's not that common,
but I agree. I, I do like that it varies.
The, you knows, you know what I mean?
But he's also clear with them.
Right. It's a different kind of,
you know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
I also feel bad for that change for you
after the second loss. Um, you know,
they just get their heads beaten
in so much. No, that's true.
Um, you know, you know, it wasn't
really much that changed. You know,
I lost two close decisions,
you know,
that that could have had two more
rounds. You know what I mean by that? Um,
as far as that goes, you know, I just, it
was learning lessons for me and I had to,
I had to make changes and a was, you
know, those are fights where, um,
the game plan was wrong. You know what
I mean? I came down a game plan it,
I didn't get hurt and you know,
I didn't get close to being submitted are
knocked out. I had the wrong game plan.
I had the wrong, you know,
the wrong people behind me,
the wrong circle around me and,
and I had the wrong game finance
get under your nose or not. Well,
I like him for the, you know,
category that was eight, you
knows. And just that short clip,
let's check out the super cut. Yeah.
See what we got. Good. Okay. Yeah. So,
but what do you do?
You know, you know, you know what I
mean? You know it, you know what I mean?
You know what I mean? You
know, um, you know, you don't,
you know, I, you know that,
you know what I mean? You
know, um, you know, you know,
yeah. You know, you know what I
mean? You know what, you know what,
you know what I mean?
And you know, you know,
I dunno.
Good world died work Lubin new man.
Oh it was great.
And he's kind of like a mellow,
he's a mellow,
but I still think that's playing a
part in how we're receiving these,
you know what I mean?
Like you're like, oh,
it's not that much because he's so chill.
Cause a lot of times you
know what it means or really
hype, you know what I mean?
Yeah, yeah. This guy really is
a kind of a, I'm saying, yeah.
You don't even really hear it sometimes.
Right, right, right. You know, you know,
you know,
you know
I gave him the Greece.
Oh yeah.
I tell him it was fine though.
Sticking name is ace and you know what
I'm saying? Kind of like fuck you. Sale.
Yeah, I loosened itself well. Yeah. Okay.
So you know what I'm saying?
That clip has made people angry.
You know food is just prison rape.
Right.
So focus it. So fuck yourself. You know,
tie loosened up a little bit. God does
that. Is there anything worse than that?
I don't know if you have someone say
anything worse to you than that. Yeah,
I'd rather just die and it's really,
remember how man,
how well thought out.
That is where they go.
The reason I give that clip
clip clip keeps playing.
He tells you so that if he complained
to the guards that he was raped,
they can check that he's got grease
on his fingers. God. So it looks like,
like you know, he figured himself, Oh my
God, it was just like to cover themselves.
So evil. Yeah. It's like that's
pretty bad. Crazy. It's pretty bad.
Yeah.
That's my favorite.
I will save all the clips we've ever
played on your mom's house. The Gay,
the gay guy getting fucked by imaginary
gay ghost. Wait, what does that guy,
homeless guy,
man ray by home almost being
raped by gay guy and now and yeah,
but I think homeless guy
getting raped by gay goes.
Yeah
man.
Are you watching it? Yeah. Shit
Wonderful.
Yeah.
Wow.
And I always am envious of the person
that recorded it cause there's one point
in the video where he's like shaking
from laughing so hard. I'm like, man,
I wish I got to cut the gay guy.
I mean the,
the homeless guy getting right
from the get go. So why don't,
why don't I get to see cool stuff?
Oh,
that's a good one. That's a classic
one too. Why can't I find the whole,
the whole reason I'm playing these,
cause I still am looking for, uh,
the ultimate, you know what I'm saying?
I can't find it. Is that the sugar night?
Oh, that's my favorite. I don't see it
anymore. I don't know where it went.
It's really, really upsetting to me
because I remember as an early on one,
you know, sometimes you, well that
was, yeah, it was one of the first, uh,
Y K W I s is, yeah. God Damn.
Pause and look. Yeah, I do actually.
Yeah. Good girl just tweeted.
Yeah. As I get left with most of my meal
on, my boyfriend goes to take a shit.
Oh yeah. Yeah. And she's got
like a half a cheeseburger.
All her fries and then she has a picture
of him walking to the toilet. Oh Man.
Girls earlier today. You did. I retweeted
it. I want to retweet that shit too, man.
Yeah. The fight is real. The flight,
the fight is real. The struggle,
the struggle for us women,
they got guys who've got to
shit halfway through the meal.
I should start a group for women who
are just stranded alone in restaurants.
You're not straight husbands and
boyfriends abandoned them to go, Shit.
That's the word story is the
story of our life together.
Please.
Yeah.
I tried to say this.
I'm one of those morning new shows
is the average total non sequitur.
Like they asked me like what can people
expect to see at your show? And I was,
I never had a job before in my life until
I started working for C in and out of
jail. You know what I'm saying?
You know what I'm saying?
Yes. The best it is the best. That was
the best. You know what I'm saying today?
Yeah. Yeah. He doesn't say shit and
he says, you know what I'm saying?
That's why it's amazing. It's
how you do. Yeah. I'm saying
that's the exemplary, you know what
I'm saying? Shit. I have a job there.
My mom was help.
Happy, happy, happy. A master of accents.
What region is that? Oh, that is,
that's probably like Northwestern Uk.
Huh?
Northwestern UK. Interesting. Yeah,
he can you pinpoint a region?
Well,
I mean specifically pacifically.
It's,
that's probably six kilometers south.
South East of Wales. Oh,
it's Welsh. Yeah. Oh,
I didn't say that. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Good.
You're really good. Yep. Anyways, hey,
so can we talk about how we got your
parents hooked on the day? They're really,
really hooked now.
First of all,
we came back from the baptism and I had
found out the top dog shit on our toilet
while we were away. Not on the in
it. Well, you know what I'm saying?
Like he used our toilet.
Yeah. And I didn't know that.
So let's back it up while it
happened. Oh, he was just like,
oh my God. Oh Buddy. He goes, it's
real neat. Uh, he goes to water,
just goes right up in the asshole and
he goes, I had to move a little bit.
You know what, to kind of hit it hit the
right spot. But he's like three wipes,
not nearly as bad.
It's real environmental to do that.
And we gave him the super deluxe.
Yeah.
There was a patriotic episode where a lot
of times we opened the Po box gifts on
patrion episodes.
Somebody sent this high grade
toilet paper from Japan.
Beautiful. Really Nice stuff. I mean, each
role is individually all that and like,
uh, Lacey, there's encroach
Whaley. Yeah. And I gave it to him.
He was like, all right. Yeah. So
excited. He was more excited than those.
I started to see his grandson.
That's what I'm saying.
I think there was Alice and then there
was toilet paper. I was really excited,
but the real kicker was
that Charo was like, oh man.
She goes, we have to get one of
these. That'd be day. Yeah. Yeah.
She's hooked actually. It's
called something else. Yeah.
I'm not sure what we have.
Uh, they have a name for it.
It's by toto. Yeah, the pain.
They come in and span, they sing a
song and then they put it in there.
It's called a washlet. Well, Ashland
and your toilet and you turned it.
It's going to take to get away from you.
How's it go?
Um,
there's nothing that a hundred,
I don't remember that being the
thing that they, him at Arbor Day.
So
he got a splash splash away.
The
Do, do, do, do, do, do Bram
due too high to go brown
in the middle of the night.
And it was terrible.
But I could of Weipa
where Eh, okay. Believe,
believer Brown Frigo is
what it is in Africa.
What about no, I know what it is.
That's another hard hitting brown.
No, it's my shot on the way to Africa.
Oh yeah. Hi Charlotte. And on the
plane, that's what it is. Okay.
Nick Hock, are you listening?
I think you found your Muse,
man.
You need
to ask him to kick her ass. Kick the
guy's ass. I can't even fucking seat.
Take himself that serious, Eh, um, we got,
I got to think of the song.
It's a song is going to happen.
It's going to have meeting. Do you
want to hear another masterful accent?
I'd love to.
Yeah.
Just tell the one demo again.
Boston.
She is Shawn. I will write your
job. Awesome. Woobox song. Wow.
We a good either carrying a machine
gun or a machete. Candy's the animal.
Should we say funny
bridge the fit where you shit nobody.
I toured the school clubs blind.
I'll go back
in your past.
That's like, like the Irish bar
guys to a degree. Like, well,
I can pick up words in there,
but that is really impressive.
That is quite an accent.
Quite his abattoir thick.
Very.
This is Jeff Jamaican. Yeah, because
my mother would pronounce it,
Hi Micah Jamaican.
She one time I went to Jamaica,
Jamaica like why did he keep saying it
like that? Why did she say it like that?
Jamaica. I don't know. She
pronounced everything wrong. Uh,
he's down. I heard him say it down
and then the restaurant, I don't know.
I had no go to the Balaclava shop.
There's a balaclava shop down the street.
Balaclava shop.
Nah Man.
Balaclava this shit that you put on
your face before you fucking pussy riot
wears them. Oh, Bella Balaclava. Okay.
I don't fucking know dude. Who knows
what the fuck this guy saying. Why
no sweat yakking
customer versus a bridge. We got the
bridge part down the bridge of Goto.
I want to take a shit in wine in the wine.
She had blonde
hair down.
I just wipe it up father.
I know that was crazy.
Florida farther. Oh,
you got to Florida now said
you think you want to be gone so you
don't to your body. Yeah. Right, right.
You got these guys were blown
away because they were bidding.
They're recording it. They're
like, this guy's accent is
take her insane. Yeah. They cannot,
they speak the same dialect.
Wow. That was intense. I'm Michelle.
I'm scared to try to and translate it.
I know that really gets code for
like and then Keel Tom Segura,
right? Yeah. Right. Yeah. Yeah.
It's the machete and hand.
The machete hasn't been to me. It's
very common though in some parts of the,
of the world because yes.
You're actually using them to walk to
get around that stuff. Yeah, of course.
The jungle. So thick. Yeah. Yeah, yeah.
Oh boy.
Um,
it's got a tick,
I guess the dog. She's another
accident. Yeah. Pretty good.
Oh Man.
Look at this fucking dude.
Holy Shit fucking thing.
I went, that's a blinder man
that you're pulling in Ga.
Come on. That's a flounder.
Let's pull it in. Jay.
Come on. No, you know it is.
We are in the fucking news,
man, guys. I think this is more
bill burr. Oh, right, right,
right,
right.
Okay.
Will you look at this shit?
Oh my God.
Jay Jay,
let's get it. Let's get it. I
wouldn't fuck with that thing.
Fucking things as a
total flow or something.
It's not a tuner on. How about
you leave it alone? Yeah.
Oh Man. Ga let you told me, didn't you?
What is that?
Oh my God, look at this thing. Oh my God.
Look at this fucking thing to
build a new hour. We share this.
It won't be Shit Jane. Oh
my God. It's a bit closer.
You can get a little fucking fishing.
What are you shitting me? That's the hook.
You can actually
bill did a video of him saying,
oh my fucking God to fish for an hour
and I bought it. Yeah, I'd be like,
it was pretty funny. Of course. Like
there's a fucking size of this thing, Jay.
Pull the fucking thing.
I would definitely watch it.
Um,
man,
this is something we've been wanting to
talk about for a while here at this is
amaze,
amaze your browns.
First.
I will read you a couple
of emails. Well, here's,
um,
wait, did you get diarrhea and
f an Africa when we were there?
I did from the salads.
Not until the very anticipating all
the tomato. Yeah, that's what I was,
I was eating tomato salads at midnight
and I finally got diarrhea and Africa and
I was expecting it much sooner.
This was on reddit about poop pile. Oh,
please. It says on a backpacking trip,
a couple of friends and I
all pooped in the same spot.
Then took turns shooting the pile with
a 38. Uh, it's from giant robot queue.
Uh, lately I've noticed in my
community could really use a poop pile.
Just hearing the main mom water champion,
speak on how the pile brought people in.
His community closer together made me
realize we need to pull our genes up and
become a family community.
I could really use some tips and advise
them how to get the momentum going on
this. I mean, I don't want
to poop just anywhere.
I want to make it somewhat discreet,
but at the same time accessible
to anyone in the neighborhood.
Any advice is appreciated. Thanks
to big bag and zigzags. Hey,
real great question and I'd love to help.
I'll tell you how we did it. Um, well,
we were in a timber wood.
North Carolina's lies, lies, lies, right.
It was a community, a, an apartment
complex that was surrounded by woods,
you know, like, like brush.
So it was real easy to
one of the backyards laid,
basically bright upon where the,
the woods started.
So we just went a few feet back into
there. And then on a tree we just built a,
um,
like a seating area and cut a hole in
it so that anybody could go up this kind
of makeshift ladder that was on a tree.
And then you just start telling
people about it. Word will spread and,
and pretty soon you'll have
mothers and fathers and
neighbor kids. You said last
week, neighbors, all of that.
What's interesting is that the story has
changed since you first told me about
how the poop pile was constructed.
No, you didn't mention a tree before.
Of course, it was never, this is the first
time I've heard of the tree and you go,
yeah, we just put, we had a ladder.
I remember the ladder. Right.
But you told me it was just a ladder
and then you would shit off the ladder.
And then that's how the poo piles started.
So it's a ladder steps,
but it's on a tree.
How does that even make sense and how
would you shit off of something like that?
Will you just sit there off the tree?
You're climbing a tree? Yeah, but,
and how do you relax enough
to shit off of a tree ladder?
Most people would go up
when they really had to go.
So it wasn't like a far as relaxing
to go. You had to shit. I mean,
a lot of people just sprayed
shit. Okay. Yeah. And,
and your toilet paper,
how did you carry that while climbing the
ladder while having to share? Go ahead.
You're not climbing on a ladder. Oh,
now you're not climbing a ladder.
Ladder ladder implies,
you know, a metal
traditional ladder, right?
These are stairs that
are nailed to a tree.
It's different than the first time
I heard about it. Well, I just,
we called it a ladder. Okay.
It's all lies. No, it's not. It.
Is there anybody out there in the city
of Los Angeles that is a certified lie
detector person stuck right into the show.
Your mom's podcast@gmail.com and I would
like to set Mr [inaudible] grew up with
a actual, the lie detector
test. I'm like, see it.
This is what people call in the pooped
off of it because you tell your dumb
friends this idiot story cause you've,
you've gotten your friend,
you've already done
this where you're like,
here are talking to Justin and then
he'll be like, yeah, boot Paul's real.
Cause they didn't talk to Casey. Yeah, we,
well it's because you've prepped
them before. I'm not a moron.
Just like this Josh Potter. It was a
doc. Sorry. With the the cigarette burns.
Pat House had house on, on your thumbs
last week. But he, he was there.
He saw it happen.
The vagrant who put cigarettes out on
your thumbs couldn't jump over that
parking meter. They
burned my thumbs. Yeah,
he was there the next day.
He saw him fresh. Okay. They
look like cigarette burns.
Okay. So are you done bluebell? Sure.
How dare you try to
support this idiotic story. Got another
email. Cookie thief theory. Hey,
Mommy's, uh, I have a theory in the
cookie. Think I'd like to explore. Yeah.
We all been racking our brains
over the past several weeks.
Wondering why Berta so fat.
I'm pretty convinced he has been
breaking into people's homes. Oh,
cramming all those sugary baked goods
down. His giant was filled belly. Yeah.
Just like a blow to Santa Claus.
Only fatter. Yup, your honor. It,
let's look at the facts.
Yana, Mr. Crusher,
Aka big fat Burke was known
acquaintance of the cookie whole. Yes.
He had first hand knowledge of the
layout of the home where the cookies were
being held.
Trail.
He's totally Yazzie was sneak in
and gobble down the fucking cookie.
I submit that we enter the cookie wrapper.
That was cares who left at the
scene for fingerprint analysis.
I'm sure we'd be able to lift the
perfect, uh, print due to the defendant.
Constantly has greasy fingers were on
the fried chicken and fatty Handley
consumes each day. I feel
this is a calculated crime
perpetrated by a season. Fat,
fat, fat, fat, fat pro. Let's
let the truth be told. Finally,
get some insight as to why Berta. So
fat. Keeping your jeans nice and tight.
Stay hydrated. Jinx chinks. Really
good point. Really great email.
Um, I would have an update by the way on
the battle, but I think I have to, uh,
at least, uh, regroup with
Bertrand first and, and,
and kind of share with him what's going
on before we dive into the numbers and
the tallies. Yeah, yeah. We
basically had a tally going,
a running tally on which team people are
on your either on team birder team Tom.
And if you're in team Bert,
you're buying a time as fat shirt.
And if you're on a team, Tom,
you're buying a bird is fat
shirt. And uh, it's been,
it's been an intense week. You,
there's a lot of back and forth.
We played a lot of promos, videos
up. Um, we really, you know,
he actually,
I was surprised,
but he actually did get a few
hardcore people on his side.
They really tried to lay me up.
I know, but it was, he's, it's,
it's pretty still feels pretty one sided
to a large degree because the truth,
you know,
and I will say this,
his most diehard like is most
devout fans are not funny.
Right. Like they're,
they're the dumbest and then
they are so dumb. And I'm like, I
know why you're a bird fan. You know?
And then like our most devoted,
devoted fans are so fucking funny or
smart and funny. Yeah. They're super,
they like comedy, right? Yeah.
But his real dot. You know,
it's funny, I just thought about this as
like, his mouth is always open. It's all,
he's always,
he's always been a mouth breather.
Just aesthetically that's
not a good intelligent.
You're also going to draw in types that
are like, yeah, yeah, of course. Yeah.
Yeah. He's, they're very dumb. Um,
why is it so fun to do
stuff to him and why?
Why I don't, I think because I have
to say this, this needs to be said,
this needs to be said.
The reason that this got legs
is misinterpreted as being,
because of me,
where my report to the FBI would be that
the real driving force behind this was
you. Oh, yes. I don't mean it. It's
not something to, to even defend.
It's because it was like week two of
the Burdis fat stuff and I was like,
eh. It's like, you know like we have
like inside jokes and you're like,
I'm not really going to do it.
And you started to go bird is still
fat and you started to tweak that and
Hashtag it and you started to say it,
man. I'm trying to be the quiet driving
because you took so much
joy in this. I know. I just,
I don't think it's something to be ashamed
of. I think you deserve the credit.
Thank you. I appreciate you giving
me credit. I feel like I did have,
I feel like you're not given credit
on it and you deserve present on it.
Thank you.
I appreciate you acknowledging me in this
whole debate and I can't wait for Bert
to a really rad.
I want him to fully get at some point
that you're driving and I like to do.
People don't realize that you're
also 10 you're friends with him,
you know what I mean? You've known him
a long on their vacations with them.
We've loved the crisis for many years,
but I like to,
I'm always the kind of shit mixer
that does it from behind the scenes.
I like to Shit Max behind and
then watch it on fault. Yeah,
like an evil. But even on those
trips now I'm thinking about it.
Even when we went to Hawaii with
them for that show, that whole trip,
you and I and his wife were like, Hey
Bert, why don't you close your mouth?
Yes.
Yeah. Yeah. Why is it so much
fun to shit on Bert? Ah, Nice.
Because you know there's something about,
you know,
he can take it and you know he likes
basically any type of attention.
That's true. So that's why it's not
like somebody who can't roll with it.
Right. If you were really devastated,
we would never do this to him. No. No.
And he'll be like, this really stinks.
I like can he goes,
do you see the videos that a blue
band put together if you guys yeah.
You haven't seen those yet? Oh my God.
It's so funny cause he's like, all right.
Yeah,
me,
it's so wordy.
I think maybe that's the joy of it too,
is that he's like, yes. Yeah.
Actually,
cause I saw the video you guys did where
you're both shirtless and talking. Yeah.
And he's holy looks a fat or is he
actually, in all honesty, I don't,
I really wouldn't know outside
of those videos what the actual,
yeah. You know, percentages
would come down to,
but he looks horrible is
in his fat shaming video.
He looks like he just got off a
bender and he's like, yeah. He's like,
I'm so fat dude is really great that he
sent those in who's trying to do some
lighting tricks. Yeah. Yeah.
Was he trying to like gas some
shadows on his shoulders and stuff?
I picked up ah, to make them appear
thinner or more muscular. Oh,
how funny. It was great. He didn't,
yeah, he was really a great,
great sport through this whole
thing. Yeah. He's great I think.
But I think the way he's
built, yeah, it, it, it, it,
the fat stays on, we say this
like it sticks to him. Right.
And it's super fat
the way that he's built.
I'm saying it's more apparent if
he has weight gain as well. Yeah.
How he gains weight. I think maybe
he looks, if he gains five pounds,
it looks funky. Put on 20 pounds. Yes.
Because of where it hangs kind of thing.
You actually is very fortunate though.
He does have that such an animal or
you can just cut out booze for a week.
He'll be losing 20 pounds.
That's the whole key to this is
that Burt can stop being fat.
If he stops drinking for a week.
It's, I know. That's all it is.
Will he's going to do it. He got so, uh,
psychologically damaged by this,
that watch.
The next time you see him you
were going to be like, oh my God.
Did you lose 30 pounds? You'll be like,
kid, it's been four days. Drink four days.
Right for you now or is it thinned
down? Yeah. You know, it's so funny.
I just remember like Leanne stories
about what an animal live at.
Like he's such an animal.
Do you know that he works out and
then he just hoses himself off and
back backyard
behind his man cave. He has like an
outdoor, he calls it an outdoor shower,
but I think he just hoses himself
down instead of showering.
Is that really surprise
you? A little. A little.
And then when he,
Leann said when he cuts his nails,
remember this,
he puts out scotch tape and then he puts
the nail clippings on the scotch tape
and then tapes it under the table.
He's a real animal.
I wanted to read you this,
but for so grow how much free time,
how does he have that much free time?
He's got two kids who's got that
kind of town was Bertrand or Leanne.
There are a lot of pronouns
out there like and bird mount.
And we're like, people were like
slowly and slowly adding more.
So the two most common
ones are she and she,
he has is traditionally
considered a male pronoun.
You cannot see another
female. Um, so, um, now,
so then they're also gender neutral
meanings attached to them at all,
which is super cool. Um, and
there are so many of them.
The most commonly used is they,
they is traditionally plural.
Commonly used is they,
they answered a plural,
but we already used in the singular
form to like maintain people's anonymity
here. Like if you just don't know what
their gender is, you'll be like, oh,
I was talking to a student and they told
me Blah, blah, blah. Totally normal. Next.
Most common.
I've seen a Z.
Z can be spelled a bunch of
different ways and it can,
okay,
you get it right.
So can I say something before we go
into the c minor you're going to read is
because, yeah, it is great.
And the thing is, is I,
I was thinking about this
guy's video all week.
I was thinking about
him and what if I did,
because I do come across people
whose gender I'm not certain of,
but I think it's more rude to be like, hey
man, what are you, what's your pronoun,
Bro?
Are you a guy or girl?
Like that seems more insensitive than
just rolling with who the person is and
being like, listen, when you're
ready to tell me, you'll tell me.
I think it should be on the person who is,
if they have a strong desire to have a
pronoun, a different of whatever. Cause I,
there are people that I
come in contact with weekly.
I would say the comedy clubs,
I don't know exactly what they are and
I just shut the fuck up about and I'm
nice to them. Of course. I, you know,
look, just be now just fucking, yeah,
be by an email. We got it says Trans
Mommy on gender pronouns. Here we go.
Okay. Okay, good. Hey, mommy's big fan.
I'm a 27 year old transgender woman who
would like to help weigh in on the whole
pronoun issue. Thank God no, we've
been wanting to see Emily personally.
I think going beyond he or she
pronouns is a bit ridiculous. I mean,
get your life.
It's not hard to tell if someone would
like to be referred to as he or she.
And it isn't hard to respect that.
Of course.
I'm a bit offended when I'm mis-gendered
because I'm obviously living life as a
woman. That makes total sense. I mean,
my jeans nowaday are the highest and Titus
probably the best plus for being both
a trans and a full on mommy.
So don't feel obligated to call
someone they because I mean, come on,
it's a bit much.
Thank you.
Although I respect it because who am
I to judge anyway? Just my thought.
Ps, you're both real mommy's tummy.
But Tommy is clearly the water champ.
Rude Hashtag [inaudible] so fat with
much love. I know what I'm saying,
Ricky.
Thank you Ricky.
But it's nice that a trans
person weighed in on gender.
Now of course the, there's somebody who's
going to hear this and be like, yeah,
but what if you're not male or female?
But you can tell that that's
also part of the thing.
Sometimes you can tell it's somebody
who is a male and he was presenting as a
female. You can tell that sometimes
if they're wearing a dress,
but maybe he looks you now it looks like
a masculine guy and address then you
know, to call that person. Is
she because she was presenting,
you know, feminine. Yeah. And you know,
a couple of emails here about,
um, about the water battle.
Um,
I had a chance to see the main mommy and
San Diego Friday night aside from the
retarded person in the front row and he
killed it about halfway through the show.
Good. Retarded. It's, I'm telling
you if your act finally doing it,
I noticed something curious.
So halfway through the show I
notice something, something curious.
Town's water was completely full. The cap
seal had clearly been broken. Okay. No.
And um, and I know I saw him bring the
bottle up to his mouth at one point.
Just led me to believe he was taking
a Yorkie sips and I was hurt. However,
someone in the crowd yelled out, hydrate
and like the champ of drinking water,
he is bullshit.
He managed to take two magnificent gulps,
nearly emptying the
bottle. Sorry Mommy. Tina,
you can't win against natural
talent like that. Great Show Tom.
Thank you very much.
And thank you to everybody that came out
to the American comedy company in San
Diego, in the Gaslamp district. I had
a great time in manly. A whole, yeah.
Yes.
Now,
don't you think a water champ does it
need to be prompted by the audience?
Someone needed to scream,
hi Tracy.
You know what I did for one show? I
walked out, I dawn Staley, she said,
I don't want him on my entrance.
Open the bottle and did it and the outlet,
drink, drink, drink, drink and I know
that other people, they were like,
why are they chug and so silly. And then
I threw the bottle and I was like, yeah.
And then I had it
full water belly for a whole show.
That's so gross.
Can I tell you somebody left
a water bottle at our house.
One of our relatives,
unreal and I have been using it all week.
It's a little car and it is fantastic.
I think it's for bicycling.
It's like a sports bottle
with a nice nipple.
It doesn't leak when you put the bottle
or two options for that of WHO's who?
Mario or her husband.
Wow.
It's my now who else drinks I done
stole your water bottle. I love it.
I've heard it seen so far. It's
clear to me, Tom is the water champ
lies.
Propaganda.
Just said there's a clip here and Tina
takes microscopic sips of water. Bullshit.
She doesn't hydrate enough.
She only throws out Yorkie says
mmm.
Is it a clip of just
set up?
It's pretty. And by the way, where'd
you find that? The way you send me.
How'd you get ahold of yet?
Yeah,
there you go. You're coughing water.
Cause I drink so much so fast. No,
it was a tiny little sip.
A tiny little sip.
Both of you right now.
Hmm.
Yeah. Well there's a lot
of, there's a lot more.
It just basically says
I'm the best or the worst.
You know what I am the new champion of
you and I discussed this a couple of
weeks back,
is that I am the alone champion.
Meaning I can be alone much
longer and better than you.
No, it's true. I'm really good at
being isolated and I love being alone.
Even more abuse me of
being the lone champion.
You acute, you're like, you can just
be a little, I want your company,
I want you to be next to me. And
somebody who's lie. That's not true.
Don't we have a joke?
Even when I want to be in a lone dog?
What's our joke when I'm in a lone dog,
what do I do? I go up to the window and I,
Babe,
you're always telling me,
you're telling me that you feel like it
doesn't even matter to me if I'm with
anybody ever and that you
want company antisocial,
you're just anti so I'm just meaning
like your like top dog where it doesn't
matter if people talk to you
or not because you're just too,
but I'm the lone champion. I'm the alone
champion. You guys know what to do.
I'm way better at solid. I grew
up alone. I'm an only child.
I hid from my parents my whole life.
I would say it's not even close.
I'm the lone champion.
You're not even in the top 10
we'll see about that.
Let's go on a meditation retreat and
see who can last longer. 25 years.
You can't even meditate. You don't
meditate. Bullshit. Bullshit.
When's the last time I did the fucking
last week I went to my class with all the
hippies.
Fucking,
here you are. You're making blue
man. Uncomfortable. What do you mean?
He said he was uncomfortable just now.
Most emotionally uncomfortable.
I don't know. Where are you? I sense
you were uncomfortable. Oh, okay.
But they are getting of control.
Corrina.
Sierra yells in this ICP clown,
bullshit,
whatever.
That's just like a little
clown gang are so insane.
Clown posse is our favorite bands.
All the juggle a family does is
sometimes they care around act.
Y'All understand what they're saying
about murder? I've don't like cops.
As a police officer get into my face,
it probably be me yelling
right back into his face.
I can a waiver Ellis never.
This is,
this is called Bitch posey rules.
No,
this is called shitty parenting. This
is the only way. Yeah. I mean, yeah,
you left. This should happen.
This should just doesn't happen.
This could have been me. You know what
I'm saying? This was my shitty parents.
You got to fuck a lot.
All kinds of stuff on.
You got to neglect the shit out of a
case of your kid that you think it's your
parents that made you go down that path.
There's no reason the kid turns goth
unless there's a lot of other stuff
happening. You know what I mean?
You don't get golf in a vacuum.
You were goth as a, as a means
of acting out, of course,
because they're ignoring
me and whatever drama,
and then you hang out with the wrong kids,
drift into bad groups whose parents
aren't paying attention to them.
And then next thing you know you're
paying your face and go into fucking dumb
concerts.
I got fat.
I used to be scared of everything.
I usually chop their heads off.
Wow.
Fucking Ted fundies trials.
That's what snagged it. Same thing. The
college night. I'm look at those eyes.
You can tell it's always in the eyes.
She's going to have problems.
Call me snake cause I unified
over chop their heads off.
She's going to be in jail.
I run away,
am disrespectful.
I do not like being told what to do.
I got into this one really serious by
and grabbed her by the neck and slander
down on the ground. Well,
it felt pretty good.
Yeah. Well, you're angry.
This is my favorite by the way.
Like in the nineties too,
when kids were bad and on Jerry Springer
and then they try to use tough love
against the kid who's already like fucked
at home. Why are you so bad? It's like,
well, because your parents suck.
Why do you think they're so bad?
It's not their fault. Unreal.
Yikes. I'm sorry Kiddo.
I'd adopt you if I could. We've got to go.
Anything else new to throw in there? No,
I love you and I'm the lone champion.
I love you buy jeans.
It's gross. It's gross.
Every time. Dead Body.
He has the whole server,
a hot pot roast
getting both 22 hospitals,
least both triglycerides,
Lipids and glucose and I put the fork
down please. She took the sword your feet,
Nicole,
you've over laddie.
It's your life.
It's going down to children's when you
can't even reach to shape those pills.
You Boba Laddie Laddie such it
got four Chan's in big old gut.
Should take a look at your diploma.
Laddie
firstly is gross.
Gross.